[Applause]
so the NBA there's two NBA teams one of
whom is a Sixers I remember the other
team but they are cutting NBA employees
to four days a week and then they will
dock their pay accordingly so you're
losing 20% of your chest
it's like full-time employee salary like
full-time full-time employees
nine-to-five with office guys I think
the more companies do this this will be
good in the long run Oh
because salaries are always gonna adjust
up but if in the same way a ton of
people are working from home and a lot
of offices are gonna be like oh we could
just have you work from home whenever
you want we don't need you in the office
and that's gonna be better in the long
run going down to a four-day workweek if
everybody does that a lot of companies
are gonna be like hey maybe we don't
need people to come in five days a week
and once this [ __ ] is over there's a
possibility we might start transitioning
to a four-day work week cuz it's like oh
we got just as much done we're just not
wasting [ __ ] time any more outside a
four-day workweek how many people really
need to be in the office like once we
realize and balance all the time
effective you can be from your home and
how costly real estate is I don't
understand why companies insist on so
that's the thing it's like you have
what's called a brick or mortar right
like you actually have the business has
it stores like on you know Fifth Avenue
things a lot of these places are lost
leaders right meaning that they lose
money but you want to have a face right
this makes sense for retail it doesn't
make sense for an advertising agency I
don't understand we're gonna have a
small office right or you can have these
work spaces but for the most part you
can stay home do your work at home and
then when you're doing your work at home
you can carve out your own [ __ ]
schedule take your lunch room you want
to take your lunch you have to be on
certain calls it's very easy or decide
to work in a communal workspace and what
if hypothetically speaking you and all
your friends work together but you have
different jobs so now let's say we have
corporate jobs you me and Alex work for
different companies but we decide to
share a workspace yeah that means we
take our lunches together that means we
go out do a workout class do whatever we
don't have to work with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that are in the office you
don't get along with you
work with people you like being around
this makes perfect sense we work is
apparently not doing well I've looked at
we works in the past I thought it was
gonna win I was wrong about we works
guys like that's what it's gonna be
we don't need offices usually the place
you're gonna run out every once in a
while when I gotta get you together well
we work is not working well because they
put themselves out as a tech company not
a real estate company ah okay
and I think tech companies get this
crazy evaluation they get like a 25 to
one evaluation and they really don't
have any tech now you're really the real
estate company so thanks exact that's
all you have a space and you rent it out
so if they came out with their IPO right
and there's like hey we're just a real
estate company so it's whatever real
estate is one to one or five to one or
whatever that is then I think they would
have been done fine but when they said
we're a tech company and then their
evaluation came out way lower than they
thought they're gonna get crushed but to
me that's what it there's another move
there where you just have office space
that people will run out for one hour
two hours at a time we'll have with the
people you like that can be their motto
that can be their slogan work with the
people you love
yeah it's go to you and your I mean you
can go to work with your wife go to work
with your boys you could switch who you
go to work with you could literally go
hey what do you guys what are you guys
doing Wednesday you guys want to work
together yeah hey well let's get the we
were balla all you need is the internet
connection yes it's a great idea I think
they just expand it too quickly we work
they go hungry and the money was cheap
they got greedy if you if you go tech to
get a higher valuation
kameena says oh you got greedy yes you
didn't want to take a long real-estate
rule read some of the earlier we works
like the one on like 14th Street around
there okay like it's always Pat I like
to deal with a couple people in there
it's always [ __ ] packing and the one
in Brooklyn Williamsburg which is fairly
new always empty yeah yeah and it was
easy to expand right cuz the economy was
[ __ ] humming and money was so cheap
like you could get money from anybody
because they're like err I want to
invest in something everything's good
but so maybe now when it downsizes maybe
now will work out better but I love the
idea of [ __ ] the office do your own work
or your time choose the people you want
to work with hey do you work better
alone then you just get you a little
[ __ ] cubicle yes and I've been
weirdly optimistic about like hey this
is all gonna be for the best in the long
run I do think some of these benefits
four-day workweek might be optimistic
but work from home is gonna be more of a
like in ten years weakest sick dude you
could if they can make this worry do
that I've been one enough for the
longest like and I've worked corporate
America since I was like 16 17 it's so
easy to switch two hours a day hours
today I mean just think about it we went
to school high school right yeah I'm
elementary through high school five days
a week yeah we get into college yeah no
mediately yeah we turn it into a
four-day school week right most of you
guys at least that's what we did we went
through four tuesday/thursday classes
and then like Monday Wednesday labs or
whatever the [ __ ] that yeah right so you
have a Monday to Thursday thing it was
very easy it was like we have Monday
Wednesday Friday but people would always
try to stack so they would have one or
two days off always sure so it's like if
we know how functional it is and we know
how easy it is to make that shift and we
didn't think that there is any less
learning per se going along yeah I think
it really worked now the question is
what happens to those jobs that matter
fact you know it might even be more
functional for businesses because you go
four days a week
full-time and then you hire people for
three day a week part-time businesses
could save money cuz you don't got to
pay part-time employees benefits health
insurance all that kind of [ __ ] and you
know what four day a week give me 11
hours alright what is it a 40-hour work
weekend give me ten hours yeah what
they've been doing to us now is making
it a kind of 50 hour work week yeah but
it's like you want me to put in 50 I'll
do four what is that 12 hour days yeah I
could do for eight to eight no but a lot
of these jobs are doing salary and so
you can do a 10-day ten-hour day
so you still salary yeah you don't pay
you overtime in the work you harder and
that's it would also kind of safeguard
against that if it's a four-day work
week because you can only work a person
in one day so much and then expect them
to come back to suborn give me four
12-hour days and then a three-day
weekend every day dude that's great for
comment how you got people going out you
got one extra brunch yeah you got one at
four restaurants and [ __ ] you got one
extra in terms of consumption it's hard
to consume when you're work in all from
nightlife is gonna pop dog Wednesday
night
yo if you're in college what's the big
party night Thursday night how about we
just make that everywhere boom yeah dude
I think as crazy as it seems for our
work week is more now there's certain
things that need staff right banks need
staff the post office needs staff courts
needs staff right like there's certain
things you actually need people there
five days because let's say you get
arrested on Thursday now you're gonna
spend [ __ ] Friday Saturday Sunday in
the tunes so there's certain things that
might change a little bit but the
regular corporate sector [ __ ] you
[Applause]
[Music]